this year we decided that we would have
an event in which people from a
different field would take a different
look at the same question and the
question was who are you so Irene Lynn
rad who is someone who studies identity
citizenship immigration is going to make
the case that you are actually your
citizenship the question about who are
you and the answer around identity isn't
just a question about you know am I a
toronto maple leafs fans versus a
kennedy infant or am i a canadian or an
american or those kind of things it's
also a question about how our identities
are constituted and in my particular
case i am elaborating a way of thinking
about this that says that public
policies what government does really has
an impact on how I see myself and how I
see myself as a member of society or a
member of different groups within that
society alex has levels a social
psychologist has done a lot of research
and he truly believes that you are your
social groups I would argue that if you
like the self as a core psychological
contract is at the center of social
behavior all social behavior is informed
by people's sense of self so you know
how if you're a woman and you've got
children how you define yourself as a
mother is going to affect how you bring
up your children quiet hertzmann who is
an epidemiologist in other words
somebody who studies the incidence of
health and illness in large populations
he's going to make the case that you are
something about the relationship between
the genes you were born with and the
environment with which her genes have
interacted from the perspective that I'm
going to bring to the discussion which
is very much about understanding how the
social world in a sense gets under our
skin and influences the way in which our
brains develop and the way in which the
rest of our biology develops such that
you get differences in health well-being
learning and behavior across the life
course in predictable ways in different
walks of life if you didn't ask the
question I think we would never come up
with adequate appropriate useful
explanations or understandings of the
world around us I think it's that
fundamental I don't think you can
understand economics I don't think you
can understand society without
understanding that question I mean the
whole point of the next big question
events is to get people to actually come
and talk with us and listen to our
researchers and discover that what
they're thinking about matters to them
the next big question is really a
wonderful bridge between those two parts
of CFR we're on the one level you have
the deep engagement with fundamental
research that has done over long time
horizons and the other pillar of the
bridge is really rooted in making sure
that that is relevant or communicated to
a broader audience